what do you see as the major engineering
or general hurdles yeah that are in the
way yeah
um so the first one is just the cost of
building a single unit
so Fusion has and is actually
interesting you talked about the about
the different models that you have so
Fusion has
um one of its interesting limitations is
that it's very hard
almost at some point becomes physically
impossible to actually make small power
units
like a kilowatt a thousand Watts you
know which is like a personal home like
you know this is about a thousand
dollars or your personal use of an
energy of electricities but like a
thousand Watts
um this is basically impossible and if
for a single you know unit to do this
um so like you're not gonna have a
fusion like power plant like is your
furnace in or your electric heater in
your home and the reason for this comes
from the fact that Fusion relies on it
being it's not just that it's very hot
it says that the fusion power is the
heating source to keep it hot so if if
you if you get if you go too small it
basically just cannot keep it hot that's
um so it's interesting is that this so
this is one of the hard parts so this
means that the individual units you know
and it's it varies from concept to
concept but the the national academies
report that came out last year sort of
put the Benchmark as being like probably
the minimum size looks like around 50
million watts of electricity which is
like another for like a meat like a
small to you know mid-sized City
actually
um so that is so that's sort of like a
scale Challenge and in fact it's one of
the reasons why in Commonwealth and
another private sector ones like we they
try to push this down actually of trying
to get to the to these smaller units
just because it reduces the cost of it
um then probably
um obviously it should obviously it's an
obvious one like achieving the fusion
State itself and High Gain Is is a hard
one what we already talked about what
kind of harder what kind of challenges
that that's achieving the right
temperature density and energy
confinement time in the fuel itself in
the plasma itself and so some of the so
some of the the configurations which are
being chosen have are actually uh have
quite a ways to go in fact I've seen
those but what their their consideration
is oh yes but by our particular
configuration the engineering Simplicity
confers like an economic Advantage even
if we're behind in sort of an assigned
sense okay which is fine this is also
what you get when you get a an explosion
in in the private sector you basically
are Distributing risks in different ways
right which makes sense
um all of that good that so what I would
say is that the the next hurdle to
really overcome is is about making that
electricity so like we need to see a
unit or several units like put using
Fusion in some way to put a meaningful
amount of energy on the grid because
this starts giving us real answers
um as to like what this is going to look
like the full end to end the full end to
end thing so Commonwealth's goal is that
I'll I'll just comment to Commonwealth
because I'll take some you know some I
get some credit for this is that the the
origins of Commonwealth were in fact in
examining that like we could see this
new technology coming forward this this
new superconducting material and the
origins of our thought process were
really around designing effectively the
pilot plant or the commercial unit it's
called Arc which is actually the step
forward after spark and that was the
orig the origins of it so all the things
that were other parts of the plan like
spark and the magnet were actually all
informed totally by building something
that's going to put net electricity on
the grid and the timing of that we still
hope is actually the early 2030s so
spark is the design of the takamakan arc
as the actual full intent thing it's
like a thing that actually puts the
energy on the grid so spark is named you
know intentionally that it's like it's
on for a short period period of time and
it doesn't have a it has yeah yeah you
know it's the spark of the fusion you
know Revolution or something like that I
guess we could call it um
yeah so those are those are so those are
sort of the programmatic challenges of
doing that and
um you know it's interesting you asked
about you talked about SpaceX so what
has evolved even in the last year or so
was in fact in March of 2022 the White
House announced that it was going to
start a program that kind of looks like
a SpaceX analogy that namely wow we've
got these things in the private sector
we should leverage the private sector
and the advantages of what they obtain
but also with the things like this is
going to be hard and it's going to cut
it's going to take quite a bit of
financing so why don't we set up a
program where we don't really get in the
way of the private sector Fusion
companies but we help them Finance these
difficult things which is how SpaceX
basically became successful through the
cots program fantastic right and that's
evolving as well too so like the fusion
ecosystem is almost unrecognizable from
where it was like five years ago around
those things how important is it for the
heads of the companies that are working
on nuclear fusion to have a Twitter
account and to be quite you said you
don't use Twitter I don't use that much
I mean there there is some element to
and I don't think this should be
discounted whatever you think about uh
figures like Jeff Bezos uh with blue
origin or Elon Musk or SpaceX
there is
a science communication yeah to put it
uh in nice terms that's kind of required
to really educate the public and get
everybody excited and sell the sexiness
of it I mean just even the videos of
SpaceX just being able to kind of get
everybody excited about going out to
space once again I mean there's all
kinds of different ways of doing that
but part I mean I guess most of the
companies do well you know is is to
advertise themselves to really sell
themselves it is yeah well actually it's
like I feel like one of the reasons on
this podcast and so like I I don't have
an official role in the company and one
of the reasons for for this was also
that it's interesting because when you
come from like you're running a company
it's it makes sense they're promoting
their own product and their own Vision
which totally makes sense but there's
also a very important role for academics
who have knowledge about what's going on
but are sufficiently distant from it
that they're not fully only so
self-motivated just by their own you
know you know projects or so forth and
for me this is I mean we we see
particularly the problems of the
distrust in technology
um and then honestly in the scientific
Community as well too it will be that
one of the greatest tragedies I would
say that if we go through all of this
and almost pull off what looks like a
miracle like Technologic and scientific
wise which is to make a fusion power
plant and then nobody wants to use it
because they feel that they don't trust
the people who are doing it or the
technology so we have to get so far out
ahead of this like so I give lots of
public lectures or things like this of
of accessing a larger range of people
we're not trying to hide anything you
can come and see you know come do tours
of our laboratory in fact I want to set
those up virtually as well too you might
look at our plasma size infusion center
YouTube channel so we are reaching out
through those meetings and it's really
important that we do those things but
it's also but also then realizing
setting up the realistic expectations of
what we need to do you know we're not
there like we don't have commercial
Fusion devices yet and you ask like what
are the challenges
I'm not going to get in into any deep
technical you know questions about what
the challenges are but it is it the
pathway not just to make fusion work
technically but to make it economically
competitive and viable so it is actually
used out in the private sector is a
non-trivial task and it's because of the
newness of it like we're simultaneously
trying to evolve the technology and make
it economically viable at the same time
those are two difficult couple tasks so
my own my own research and my own drive
right now is at Fantastic Commonwealth
Fusion systems is set up we have a
commercialization unit of that
particular kind which is going to drive
forward a token back in fact I was just
there there's discussions there's
there's dialogues going on around the
world with other kinds of ones like
Stellar Raiders which prefer different
kinds of challenges and economic
advantages but what we have to I know
what we have to have what we have to to
have is a new generation of integrated
scientists technologists and Engineers
that understand like how what needs to
get done to get all the way to the goal
line because we don't we don't have them
now like a multi-disciplinary yeah
exactly what's required I mean you're
talking about uh you said that Fusion is
quote the most
multi-disciplinary field you can imagine
yes yeah why why is that what are the
yeah well because because most of our
discussion that we've had so far is
really like a physics discussion really
so which don't don't
neglect physics is at the for origin of
this but I've already we touched on
plasma physics and nuclear physics which
are basically two you know somewhat
overlap and independent disciplines then
when it comes to the engineering it's
almost everything so so why is this well
let's build let's build an electromagnet
together okay what is this going to take
it's going to take
um it's basically electrical engineering
computer and so you under understand
what how it goes together and what it
happens computational engineering to
model this very complex integrated thing
materials engineering because it's this
you're pushing materials to their limit
with respect to stress and so forth
takes cryogenic engineering which is
sort of a sub-discipline but cooling
things to extremely low temperatures
probably some kind of chemistry thing in
there too well actually yeah which tends
to show up in the materials and that's
just one of the sub components of it
like almost everything gets hit in this
right so you're and you're also in a
very integrated environment because in
the end all of these things while you
isolate them from each other in a
physics sense in an engineering sense
they all have to work like seamlessly
together so it's one of those
um I mean I've in my own career I've
basically done Atomic physics
spectroscopy you know plasma physics uh
iron etching
um
so this includes Material Science
um uh something called mhd even
magnetohydrodynamics and now all the way
through like I I'm not even sure how
many different careers I've had it's
also by the way this is also an um a
recruiting stage for like young
scientists thinking to come in like my
comment to sign is if you're bored
infusion you're not paying attention
because there's always something
interesting to go and and do so that's a
really important uh part of what we're
what we're doing which isn't new in
Fusion actually and in fact is in the
roots of of what we've done at MIT but
holy cow like the proximity
of of possibility of commercial Fusion
is the new thing you know so my
catchphrase is like you might be
wondering like why aren't we doing all
these things like why weren't we pushing
towards economic fusion and new
materials and new methods of heat
extraction and so forth because
everybody knew Fusion was 40 years away
and now it's four years away